Disculpe disculpe puedo hacerle una
pregunta me llamo Pascal Hola Pascal
Cuál es su relación con la moda
creo que tengo una relación bastante
sana con la moda la valoro le tengo
respeto me conmueve y también me
divierto con ella es un arte
absolutamente es un arte al 100%
[Música]
la moda un arte Sí pero aplicado Y ese
es precisamente el adjetivo que mejor
describe las colecciones de otoño
invierno 2023 2024 presentadas en París
se acabaron los adornos y la alta
calidad del trabajo aunque no parezca
afectar mucho a estos fans que acudieron
sobre todo a animar sus estrellas los
influencers invitados a la casa dio
[Aplausos]
cuando te vistes por la mañana Puedes
ponerte una armadura Puedes ponerte un
escudo Puedes ponerte una extensión de
tu personalidad Y a veces es más fácil
llevar algo puesto que decirlo para
transmitir tu mensaje y la ropa Es algo
más que ropa sobre todo la de dior Por
supuesto que me habla
llevo tres años en plena semana de la
moda y la semana de la moda femenina es
muy importante para mí porque todas
somos mujeres
muy a menudo y ahí lo tienen celebrando
las mujeres y a la moda
en una escenografía concebida por la
escultora Johana Vasconcelos la artista
portuguesa se hizo famosa a principios
de los años 2000 con la novia una obra
Monumental creada a partir de 25.000
tampones para Dios utilizó
principalmente el arte de la costura el
punto y el crochet
esta pieza está inspirada en las
valquirias las diosas noruegas que
salvan a los valientes Guerreros del
campo de batalla
de hecho es un encuentro entre dos
dimensiones
el hecho de que la moda las artes
contemporáneas y las artes visuales
puedan estar todas juntas
que todos podamos compartir lo que
tenemos y hacer un mundo más bello y
Pacífico
[Música]
la idea de esta colección se me ocurrió
pensando en los años 50
no nos damos cuenta y fue una sorpresa
para mí Tenía la idea de que los años 50
eran más cercanos al cine estadounidense
pero la situación era muy diferente en
Europa sobre todo en París y también en
Italia porque era después de la Segunda
Guerra Mundial
[Música]
y no hay que olvidar que en París en los
años 50 las mujeres tenían derecho al
voto y que el segundo sexo se publicó en
1949 en París estaba evidentemente en
contacto con su hermana
pero también con
que también era cliente de la casa dior
[Música]
personalidades fuertes Muy resilientes
para extra lo que las convertía en
mujeres independientes
[Música]
esta noción de feminismo es
esperanzadora Pero también es un mensaje
comercial
lo que vemos es que en las cifras si nos
fijamos en los últimos resultados de
leve match funciona muy bien en general
en cada colección siempre hay un pequeño
mensaje aunque sea subliminal en torno a
este tema es extraordinaria sabe crear
un ambiente y al mismo tiempo se
concentra en el detalle del producto Así
que es fantástica la moda es por tanto
el encuentro de una historia y un
producto en el siglo XIX el general
francés Alexis lot para celebrar el arte
ecuestre compuso este lema que se ha
convertido en imprescindible tranquilo
adelante derecho está la Macarena que No
asistió al Cat noir pero siempre ha
montado en familia envió un susurrador
para escenificar la historia de su
colección la configuración consistía en
situar al público en ambos lados esta
era la primera configuración con un
pasillo en el medio donde debían
circular los caballos pero era demasiado
estrecho Así que sugerí que pusieran las
gradas en un solo lado y así funciona no
paraba de decirme que estaba loca
mi mensaje podemos vivir en armonía con
otras criaturas podemos tener una moda
maravillosa bellamente elaborada
Temporal y diseñada sin necesidad de
matar animales
podemos celebrar que vivimos en armonía
con ellos luego tuvimos a Jean fan El
encantador de caballos franceses y sus
magníficos caballos salvajes y esta
relación entre los caballos y las
modelos seguían diciendo Oh esta energía
viene de los caballos es una energía que
nos cura y luego los patrones que
pusimos en las prendas de punto
procedían de las mantas para caballos
pero también de fotografías de mi madre
de mis hermanas porque los Mccartney
siempre hemos montado a caballo intenté
celebrar la moda pero también a la
sostenibilidad
es él es una mujer poderosa
es una pionera
hace cosas que nunca se han hecho en la
moda me encanta me encanta por eso
y es una chica Así que es muy bueno
utiliza únicamente materiales
procedentes de hongos algodones
regenerados residuos alimentarios
reciclados para una moda suave y cuidada
[Música]